high breath that's what you got to be
yeah if you want to do that stuff then
you got to be
it's got to be you got to be at that you
know now i mean you want to be at that
level you're
you'll eventually get at that level but
the point of it is
i we want to hear what they think about
things and
so you're they that's what they do and
they give you that
they you know if you watch bill maher
like you're going to go watch his show
and be like oh i want to know
this guy's opinion on all this stuff or
whoever it could be
and so unless you're do if that's your
world then yeah dive into that
side of things and if your world's not
that mine tends to not be that it's more
stories and trying to be relatable uh
and so you you do i mean do what i you
know
just talk about your life like and just
make yourself make it very
you know personal in you as a comic
and then that helps when you make it
personal it just you know i don't know
you want everybody's got to be they do
want your opinion everybody's got to be
like i want to see
you like if you're whether you're
chappelle or whoever
if you're whether you're talking about
politics or you're just talking about
going to the gas station everybody's got
to want to see
you the comedian go through that
experience so
that's what you have to be able to
that's what you're kind of selling to
the audience because you got to be like
here's me going to this you want the
audience to kind of be when they watch
it
like i could see this guy doing this
this is what he does
like that's that means they're buying
into what you're
what you they they know who you are and
that's when you get to like
you get to another level where then
you're like you kind of got your
that's like your voice like kind of
thing
where you get your voice and you're kind
of like all right like you know i don't
know
i get told a lot like people are like oh
you remind me of my brother
or something like that that's like what
i'm trying to do
like i'm not saying i started knowing
that yeah but
like you want to be their brother their
friend or you want to be like oh you're
like my husband
or your wife's like my wife like
whatever whatever they can do to like
relate to you is you know
the the what you have to be doing yeah
and there's people
in the the chat definitely your
your style and delivery are something
that a lot of um
a lot of comedians i mean i've talked to
i can't remember what comedian it was it
may have been like sam muriel but it was
like
a lot of your jokes i don't know if it's
what you're saying if it's how you're
saying it but it's like
the math isn't always there but it like
crushes
and like how were you able to bring in
that
like as comedians we want to be more
personable on stage and
like actually connect with people like
you do with your audience so what was
that process of like
finding your voice
uh i mean you know you still do it like
i do think i
i never liked that i know i'm just
saying like what everybody always says
but like uh and the fact that like you
never really find your voice
you are always searching for your voice
there's still somewhat like i think uh
mark maron is one of the best at his
voice
like what he is on stage is pretty
similar to offstage
and that's where you're i think that's
where your voice is is the fact that
like unless you're doing like
you know uh larry the cable guy or
something like if you're doing something
which is great like it's fine like
unless you're doing something that
you're you know personas
just your character or whatever is it's
trying to just be
as similar as you are off stage on stage
because once you do that there's an old
uh as louis c.k said in an interview
a long time ago about he one the older
he got it's like
his jokes are easier to write because
everything you say is funny
and everybody like kind of thinks what
you say is funny because you that means
you have your voice
that means everything that you say is
like the way i say it
or what the way i do whatever is like
funny so you get
and it's a slippery slope because you
got to be careful with it because you
don't that's how you can become
bad too because people are people like
you know are just like yeah they're
laughing at everything and you're not
getting like a true
test of like is this stuff good or not
you're just because they like you
like now when i go on stage we're doing
theaters and people are very excited
so when i go out i can tell that like
they're excited to see me they're
excited to be
in the room and but you got to make sure
that you're
still bringing it or otherwise you're
like i mean you could really
drop off and it become a problem uh
but finding your voice is like it just
takes a
long time i always when i i never i've
never sat down and wrote
word for word uh i've tried that there's
an old patricia bill
i remember patrice o'neill i think him
and burr
they told me that like it was like you
didn't want to
write it out word for word you because
if you don't do that it'll kind of
change every time
like every time you say it and not not
the bones of the joke the joke's going
to be working the same way
but your hands and your uh and your
these and like the little sentences like
that
that stuff changes and then that rhythm
kind of changes and so it kind of feels
it's very conversational
and so you're trying to kind of like or
what i try to do is you're trying to
hide
the joke a little bit so you're trying
to hide you know i'm trying to talk the
way that i
talk and i always get told i say like a
lot and
you know uh but it's like it's just how
people talk